Well
you might as well start by writing down
that url.
I'll show it to you again at the end of
class.
That's where the syllabus is.
The syllabus will tell you pretty much
everything you need to know about the
class.
The,
there's a text,
this is it.
It consists of readings from a larger
text.
I use it because it's old,
but a lot of the theorists that we're
going to talk about
are also old.
And so I found this particular text
accurate and many of the people that
we're going to talk about
are very,
uh,
very sophisticated views of personality.
And I think that it does you a
disservice unless you read something
that's sufficiently sophisticated so
that you actually understand at least to
some degree what the people that were
going to study,
we're talking about,
we might as well start,
I suppose with a definition of
personality,
it's hard to define something that's
that general because
when you're speaking about human beings,
it's not that simple to figure out what
constitutes personality and what
constitutes something else.
But
so I'm going to hit at it from a couple
of different perspectives.
And while I'm doing so I would like you
also to consider
the nature of what you're going to
learn.
Human personality is essentially
unfathomable.
Human beings are unbelievably
complicated and and we're nested in
systems that are also unbelievably
complicated.
There are more patterns of connections
between neurons in your brain.
Then there are sub atomic particles in
the universe by a substantial margin.
You can look up Gerald Edelman if you
want to find out about that.
And so it's not unreasonable to point
out that you're the most complicated
thing we know of by many orders of
magnitude and the probability that you
can understand yourself in anything
approaching totality is extraordinarily
low.
So this makes the study of personality
something very
daring and hopeless and complicated.
Now we're to cycle through a
very large number of theorists.
And what you'll find is that although
there are commonalities between them,
there are market differences.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
what's the point of studying this
sequence of theorists and ideas?
If there's no point of agreement between
them.
Now,
I would say first there are points of
agreement between them.
Although personality hasn't advanced to
the point where I would say that we have
a homogenous theory that's free of
internal contradictions.
But I would also say that
personality is a hybrid discipline.
It's partly science
but it's partly engineering.
The clinical element of it I would say
is more like engineering.
And what engineers do is try to do
things.
They tried to make something happen and
they are informed by theory,
but the point is still to build
something.
And when you're working as a clinical
psychologist and most of the initial
theorists that we'll discuss for the
first little more than a third to a half
of the chorus or clinical theorists,
they're trying to build something and
they're dealing with very,
very difficult
conceptual problems because
they're either trying to cure mental
disorders or maybe even unhappiness and
trying to bring about health.
And the problem with that is that it's
not a straight forward thing to define a
mental disorder from a scientific
perspective because what's healthy
mentally and what's not is partly social
judgment.
And it's partly socially constructed and
it partly has to do with norms.
And it partly has to do with ideals
because you might also say that to be
healthy is to be normal,
but you could also say that to be
healthy is to be ideal.
And then of course you run into the
problem of having to conceptualize an
ideal and it isn't self evident that
science is capable of conceptualizing an
ideal because ideals tend to fall into
the domain of moral judgments,
say,
or philosophical judgements rather than
scientific judgements per se.
So what I would say to you is that
it would be worthwhile to approach this
course as if you were an engineer of the
human spirit,
an engineer of your own spirit to begin
with,
but also an engineer of the spirits of
other people.
Because as you interact with other
people,
you inevitably tell them what you want
and what you don't want.
When they give you what you want
and what you admire,
you respond positively to them.
You pay attention to them,
you smile at them,
you focus,
you focus your thoughts on them,
you interact with them.
Then you reward them for acting in a
particular manner.
And when they don't respond the way that
you want,
then you punish them with a lock or by
turning away or by rejecting their
friendship or when were a child by
refusing to play for them,
play with them and so
we're engaged in the co creation of
personalities,
our own and others and that also brings
up the same question,
what is it that we are all collectively
trying to be
and trying to create?
I suspect that you all have the
experience of falling short of the
ideal,
an ideal that you hold for yourself or
an ideal that other people hold for you.
I suspect that you all feel the negative
consequences of falling short of that
ideal.
Freud would conceptualize that as the
superego imposing its judgment on the
ego,
you being ego,
the superego being
a hybrid I suppose of
external external forces and also your
internalization of those judgments and
forces.
Now personality per se I would say
has these elements of ideal and how
structural elements of oil as well and
we're going to talk about those more in
the second half of the class.
The structural elements can be lined up
and outlined more scientifically.
The second half of the cow class
concentrates more on
physiology,
brain physiology and on statistical
approaches to the description of
personality.
Um,
I suppose you might say that that
outlines the territory.
The course is called personality and its
transformations because
we have personalities.
That's who you are now.
But our personalities are also capable
of transformation of change.
I mean obviously we think about that is
learning.
Um,
some of that might be regarded as
factual learning and some of it might be
regarded as learning how to perceive and
behave.
And I would say that the clinical
psychologists that will cover to begin
with
are much more concerned with the nature
of the implicit structures that shape
your perceptions and also the implicit
structures that shape your behaviors and
how they're integrated in relationship
to your negative emotion,
health and wellbeing.
Whereas the thinkers in the second half
are more concerned about laying out the
structural elements of those features
and relating them to underlying say,
mechanistic phenomena,
making the assumption which seems
warranted,
that there's some relationship between
your personality and the manner in which
your brain functions.
I'm going to try to provide you with a
Meta narrative that will help you unite
these different theories.
I've often found it useful when I'm
trying to remember something to have a
story to hang the fact on.
Otherwise you're faced with the
necessity of doing nothing but
memorization.
And it isn't obvious to me that
memorization actually constitutes
knowledge.
Um,
what constitutes knowledge is that
generation of a cognitive structure that
enables you to conduct yourself more
appropriately in life.
And so I suppose you might say that of
course in psychology you could argue
that of course in psychology,
especially in personality is of course
in applied wisdom as well.
Assuming that wisdom is in part your
capacity to understand yourselves so
that you don't,
so that you don't present too much of an
intolerable mystery to yourself.
And also to understand others so that
you can predict their behavior,
understand their motivations,
and negotiate with them,
listen to them and formulate joint games
with them so that you can integrate
yourself reasonably well with another
person,
with a family and in society.
Well,
the structural elements of personality
might be regarded as the implicit
structures that govern your perception
and that tilt you towards certain kinds
of behaviors.
I can give you some examples.
We can talk about the big five model
just briefly.
The big five personality model is a
statistical model,
which we'll cover in detail,
trained by trait there partly during the
second half of the course.
The way that the big five was generated
was that it's stretton being generated
over about 50 years that personality
psychologists gathered together
adjectives within the English language
first that were used to describe human
beings as many adjectives as they could
collect and then subjected them to a
process called factor analysis.
And what factor analysis does is enable
you statistically to determine in some
sense how similar adjectives are to one
another.
So,
for example,
if you gave a thousand people a list of
adjectives to describe themselves with
and one of the adjectives was happy and
another of the adjectives was social,
you'd find that those who rated
themselves high on happy would also rate
themselves high on social.
And those who rated themselves low on
happy would also rate themselves low on
social.
And by looking at those patterns of
Covariation,
you can determine what the essential
dimensions are of human personality.
One of the dimensions is roughly
happiness.
That's extroversion.
Another dimension is neuroticism.
It's a negative emotion dimension.
So if you ask someone if they're anxious
and they score high,
say on a scale of one to seven,
they're also likely to score high on
another item that says that they're sad.
And it turns out that negative emotions
clump together.
And so that people who experience more
of one negative emotion have a
propensity to experience more of all of
them.
There's another dimension called
agreeableness.
And agreeable people are self
sacrificing,
compassionate and polite.
If you're dealing with an agreeable
person,
they don't like conflict,
they care for other people.
Um,
if you're dealing with an agreeable
person,
they're likely to put your concerns
ahead of theirs.
They are non competitive and
cooperative.
It's a dimension where women are women
score more highly than men on
agreeableness across cultures including
those cultures where the largest steps
have been taken towards producing an
egalitarian social circumstance like
Scandinavia.
Actually the gender differences in
personality there are larger than they
are anywhere else.
Um,
another trait is conscientiousness.
Conscientiousness is an excellent trait
if you want to do well in,
in school and in work,
especially if you're a manager and
administrator.
I can't say we understand a lot about
conscientiousness,
although it,
it reliably emerges from factor analytic
studies of adjective groups across
different countries.
Conscientious people are diligent,
industrious and orderly.
Their orderliness tilts them towards
political conservatism by the way,
because it turns out that your inbuilt
temperament,
your inbuilt personality,
which constitutes a set of filters
through which you view the world also
alters the manner in which you process
information and influences the way that
you vote.
And so you might say,
and I do believe that this is true,
are we've been doing a lot of research
on this as of late.
The more accurate a measure you take of
someone's political beliefs,
the more you find that personality is
what's predicting them.
And I think that's a reasonable thing to
think about because you know,
you have to,
you have to figure out ways of
simplifying the world,
right?
Because you just can't do everything.
And so people are specialized,
they have specialized niches that they
occupy and you could think about them as
social niches.
A niche is a place where your particular
skills would serve to maintain you.
And so if you're extroverted,
you're going to look for a social niche
because you like to be around people.
And if you're introverted,
you're going to spend much more time on
your own.
And so if you're an introverted person,
for example,
you're going to want a job where you're
not selling and where you're not
surrounded by groups of people who are
making social demands on you all the
time because it will wear you out.
Whereas if you're extroverted,
that's just exactly what you want.
And so the extrovert sees the world as a
place of social opportunity and the
introverts sees the world as a place to
retreat from and spend time alone.
And it turns out that both of those
modes of being are valid.
The issue,
at least to some degree,
is whether or not you're fortunate
enough to match your temperament with
the demands of the environment.
And I suppose also whether you're
fortunate enough,
fortunate enough so that you're born in
an era where there actually is a niche
for your particular temperament because
it isn't necessarily the case that that
will be the case.
Imagine that all of these temperamental
dimensions very because of evolutionary
pressure,
right?
So there's a distribution of
extroversion,
a normal distribution.
Most people are somewhere in the middle.
And then as you go out towards the
extremes,
there are fewer and fewer people.
And what that means is that on average
across large spans of time,
there have been environments that match
every single position on that
distribution with most,
most of the environments matching the
center.
Because otherwise we wouldn't have
evolved that way and so sometimes being
really extroverted is going to work well
for you in a minority of environments,
a minority of niches and sometimes it's
just going to be a catastrophe.
I suspect for example,
that if you live in a tyrannical society
where any sign of
of,
of
personally oriented activity is likely
to get you in trouble,
that being extroverted and low in
neuroticism wouldn't be a very good idea
because you're going to be mouthy and
happy and saying a lot of things unable
to keep your thoughts yourself and
you're going to be relatively fearless.
Now I don't know that for sure because
we haven't done the studies that
precisely match temperamental proclivity
to environmental demand,
but you get what I mean,
so conscientious people anyways,
conscientious people are industrious and
orderly.
We know a little bit about orderliness.
It seems to be associated strangely
enough with disgust sensitivity,
which I suppose isn't that surprising.
You know,
if you take an orderly person and you
put them in a messy kitchen,
they respond with disgust and want
nothing more than to straighten it all
out and organize it and clean it.
And there's tremendous variability in
orderliness.
Um,
and as I said,
orderliness predicts political
conservatism.
It's not the only thing,
but it's certainly one of the things.
MMM.
The correlation between
conscientiousness and grades,
it's about 0.4.
It's about 16% of the variance.
It's,
it's the second best predictor of
university grades after intelligence.
And we'll talk about intelligence during
this course to intelligence is actually
a relatively straightforward concept.
I don't think I'll get into it today,
but conscientious people,
their industriousness and their
orderliness makes them schedule their
time so they make efficient use of their
time.
They use schedules and that sort of
thing.
We haven't been able to figure out
anything about the underlying biology or
psychology of industriousness.
We've,
we've tried really dozens and dozens of
tests attempting to find a laboratory
measure on which industrious people do
better.
And we failed completely.
And there's no animal models of
industriousness either.
And so I would say it's great mystery
that remains at the heart of trade
psychology.
Um,
and maybe it's a human specific
category,
you know,
I mean,
you can think of sled dogs maybe of
being industrious and maybe and maybe
sheep dogs and animals that work like
that,
but of course they've been trained by
human beings.
So,
but it isn't obvious that animals are
industrious the same way we are.
I mean,
industriousness involves sacrificing the
present for the future,
something like that.
And it seems like you have to be able to
conceptualize time in order to sacrifice
the present for the future.
One of the things that I would recommend
that you do as students,
um,
in this course and maybe in every course
speaking of industriousness is come up
with a plan of attack for the course and
use a scheduler.
You know,
if you treat your university career like
a full time job,
you're much more likely to succeed.
And if you keep up on the readings and
you keep up on the,
on the essays and all of that,
then you're much less likely as well to
fall into despair when you get too far
behind.
Using a google calendar or something
like that to organize a schedule for the
entire semester at the beginning of the
semester can be invaluable,
especially if you're not very
industriousness,
very industrious because it can keep you
on track.
And one of the things we know about
industrious people is that they are very
good at using schedules and it planning
the use of their time.
And so I would like to say that you
should all be smarter,
but I don't know how you could be
smarter.
We don't know anything about how to
improve intelligence.
And I suppose we don't really know
anything about how to improve
industriousness either.
But I can tell you that people who are
industrious come up with a strategy for
solving the problem that's ahead of them
and then they do whatever they can to
stick to the strategy.
And so for example,
if you sat down today or tomorrow for a
couple of hours,
three hours and you filled in a google
calendar,
whatever you happen to use with a
strategy for studying and a list of when
all your assignments are due and all of
that,
and when you're going to sit down and
study,
then you won't be in a position where
you have to cram for 10 hours a day
hopelessly right before you know an
important exam.
It's also a very ineffective way of
studying.
By the way,
I'm being,
first of all,
people who cram for 10 hours say they're
studying for 10 hours,
but they rarely are because,
well,
I can't study for 10 hours.
I don't have the power of concentration
that would enable me to do that for that
prolonged period of time.
I can manage about three hours of
intense intellectual activity before I'm
pretty done and it's also the case that
if you study and then sleep and then
study and then sleep and then study and
then sleep,
you space it out,
then you're much more likely to
remember.
It's also much more likely that you're
much more likely to remember if you try
to recall the material.
And so highlighting in that sort of
thing isn't very useful.
But reading,
closing the book,
summarizing what you've read without
opening the damn book,
that's useful.
And the reason for that is that you're
practicing remembering and that's what
you have to practice.
If you're practicing memorization,
you have to practice remembering.
You don't just go over the thing over
and over.
That'll help you with recognition
memory,
but some,
but it won't help you with recall
memory.
Anyways,
the last trade is openness.
Openness is a creativity trait.
It's also associated with intelligence
in that intelligent people,
and I'm speaking technically of Iq,
tend to be higher in,
tend to be more creative,
which is hardly surprising.
Creative people are more likely to be
liberal politically by the way.
Um,
they like novelty.
They like aesthetics,
they like fiction,
they like movies,
they like,
are they like poetry?
There's something about them that grants
them.
Anesthetic sensitivity and,
and that's,
uh,
that's an inbuilt trait and it's not the
case by the way,
that everyone's creative.
In fact,
far from it.
Ah,
we've used the creative achievement
questionnaire to you measure people's
creativity.
I'll talk to you about that later in the
class.
And the creative achievement
questionnaire takes 13 dimensions of
creativity.
So you know,
writing,
dancing,
acting,
scientific investigation,
entrepreneurial activity,
architectural activity,
cooking,
um,
there's a,
there's a handful of others,
singing,
et Cetera,
you know,
the sorts of things that you would
assume that people could be creative
about.
And then it asks people to rate
themselves on a scale from one to 10 on
their level of achievement with regards
to all those creative domains.
With zero being,
I have no training or proficiency in
this area,
and 70% of people score zero across the
entire creative achievement
questionnaire.
A tiny proportion of people are outliers
way out.
They're creative in many dimensions
simultaneously and exceptionally
creative.
And it turns out as you'll find out that
that pattern,
which is called a prieto distribution,
where most people stack up at zero and a
few people are way out on the creative
end,
characterizes all sorts of
distributions,
like the distribution of money,
for example,
which is why 1% of the people have the
overwhelming majority of the money.
It's a different 1% across time.
It he'd like it churns,
and you're much more likely to be in the
1% if you're older,
logically enough,
because one of the things you do as you
age is you trade youth for money.
If you're fortunate,
I don't think the trade is really worth
it,
but that's the best you've got.
So anyways,
those particular traits,
you can think of those as ways that you
simplify the world,
right?
There's lots of different places that
you can act in the world and there's
lots of different ways you can look at
it and survive.
That's why you can be a plumber and a
lawyer and an engineer,
and they,
those all work,
right?
Even though they're very different modes
of being and you can have different
personalities and survive as long as
you're capable of finding the place
where your particular filters and
behavioral proclivities match the demand
of the environment.
And a huge part I would say of
successful adaptation is precisely that.
Are there other elements of personality
too?
One of the things that I've been struck
by,
and this is actually one of the
criticisms I have of the psychoanalysts
and the clinicians in general,
even though I have great admiration for
them and would say that what they have
to say is very much worth listening to
is that it's not obvious that your
personality is inside you.
You know,
you think you know a human being is a
strange multilevel thing and you might
ask yourself,
well for example,
no,
is your mother more a part of you then
your arm or maybe even more precisely,
is your child more a part of you then
your arm?
It's certainly people will do
drastically self sacrificing things to
maintain the lives of their children.
And so you're,
you're a person and you're made out of
all sub,
sort of subcomponents of,
of a person,
none of which you can see when you look
at a person,
all the complicated machinery inside you
that makes you who you are.
And then outside of that,
of course he are nested in all sorts of
complex systems.
So you're part of a family and,
and you're part of a community and
that's part of a province.
And that's part of a state.
And that's part of an international
consortium of states.
And that's part of an ecosystem.
And how you make a distinction between
you and the systems that you're embedded
in is also an extraordinary difficulty.
And,
and,
and in one of the things that you have
to do as a clinical psychologist,
for example,
if you're trying to diagnose someone
with depression,
is that you think,
well,
this person's dreadfully unhappy.
Well,
you can think about that as a problem
with their psychological adjustment.
You know,
the way that they're learning,
looking at the world.
But if you look at the epidemiological
literature,
for example,
one of the things that you find is that
very many people have a first depressive
episode after something genuinely
terrible has happened to them,
right?
They've lost someone or they've become
injured or or they've become unemployed
because unemployment is a terrible shock
to people and it's not precisely self
evident that you can consider someone
who's unhappy and desperate because they
no longer have a job depressed.
They're certainly sad and they're not
doing very well,
but the fact that they no longer have an
income is actually something with
dramatic practical consequences and
treating that as if it's a mental
disorder seems to be counter productive.
It's also the case for example,
that if you're,
if someone comes into you to talk to you
and they're very upset and they may
manifest the signs of say,
an anxiety disorder or again,
depression or or other other clinical
features for that matter,
you have to do a careful analysis of
their manner in which they're embedded
in their family.
Because,
and this is something that we'll talk
about quite
thoroughly when we come to discussing
Freud,
is that,
well,
you know,
it's not like everybody's families are
necessarily particularly happy places to
be.
You know,
I mean,
human beings are very dependent.
We have a very long period of
dependency,
partly because we're so cortically hyper
developed.
It takes a very long time to program us
into something that's vaguely capable of
maneuvering on its own and that produces
of course the very tight familial bonds
that we all,
that we all desperately require because
who wants to be alone in the world?
But it also,
it also exposes us to the probability of
becoming entangled into even
multigenerational family pathology.
And it isn't obvious always and
certainly hasn't been to me when I've
seen my clients.
That fundamental problem with the client
is the client.
Sometimes the fundamental problem is
is the family
and and perhaps that person has been
identified as the problem person.
It's rather convenient for everyone who
involved to make that presupposition.
It's also the case that this is the
Friday and idea.
Fundamentally,
this is the depaul idea,
that it's very easy for people to become
over dependent on their parents and for
the parents to facilitate that.
And then for the primary developmental
problem for the individual,
in fact,
to become free of the interfering
elements of the family so that they can
exist as independent individuals.
Well,
and then of course there are cultural
variations in that that make that
proposition complex,
but that's a fundamental tenant,
say a Freudian psychology.
A lot of the clinical psychologists,
all of whom that we're going to study,
have a pronounced Western orientation.
One of the fundamental presuppositions
is that part of the hallmark of positive
psychological development is the
creation of an individual that's capable
of acting independently.
And that's,
I would say,
an implicit ideal that lurks at the
bottom of the clinical presuppositions
of all the theorists that are classic
psychologists.
So yeah,
now it's a very old picture.
Okay.
It's Jonah emerging from the whale.
It's a variant of a myth.
The Myth is the dragon myth.
I suppose the Dragon Myth is that
there's a dragon that lives under the
ground that's eternal.
And now and then it rises out of the
ground to threaten the state and someone
within the state determines to go
confront the dragon voluntarily and does
so and then brings back something of
great value.
Sometimes if the,
if the hero is generally male,
sometimes the thing of great value is a
female that the dragon has kidnapped.
That's a St George Story and sometimes
it's gold and other treasure,
like in the story of the Hobbit and
story that you all know very well,
it's a classic hero story.
And the hero's story is another
fundamental element of the clinical
theories.
I would say it's predicated on the idea
that you learn through voluntary contact
with that that frightens or disgusts you
and that's a hallmark of psychoanalytic
theory.
Young Carl Young who will discuss in
detail said his primary dictum was in
steer Colinas invented tour,
which I'm sure I'm massacring because
it's Latin,
but it meant in filth that will be
found.
And one of the hallmarks of the clinical
theories is that within the confines of
everyone's experience,
and you could think about this as
experience out in the world or
experience in the unconscious mind,
there are
dirty little secrets let's say,
and skeletons and
dreadful old fears and remnants of abuse
and memories of pathological behavior
and failures of courage that you leave
you undeveloped perhaps out of
avoidance,
and that the psychoanalytic process is
precisely the careful encounter with
those forgotten and and repressed
elements of the self in the hope that a
clear encounter will redeem them,
unite them with the remainder of your
personality and make you make you
stronger in consequence.
And I would say that that's just a
variant of the manner in which human
beings learn.
And we'll talk about this more in
relationship to piaget because you
always learn when you're wrong,
which is very annoying.
Now what do you learn when you're
correct you,
you're walking in the world,
you're operating in the world,
you have a sense of what you want to
have happen.
You're always looking at the world
through this sense of what you want to
have happen.
You're acting so that what you want to
have happen will happen.
And when it happens,
well then you're happy because,
well first of all,
you get what you want and that's good.
Maybe depending on what you want.
But it's also good because if you get
what you want when you act,
then it turns out that your model of how
to act is valid right now.
Outcome that you get what you want
indicates no error on the part of your
model.
But it's very frequently the case that
when you act to get what you want,
you don't get what you want.
And then that's unpleasant because you
don't get what you want.
But it's even more unpleasant because it
brings with it the hint of a suggestion
that the manner in which you're
construing the world is incorrect at
some indeterminant level.
So for example,
if you tell a party,
tell a joke at a party,
you presume that people will attend.
And then when they hear the joke,
they will laugh.
And then if you tell the joke and it
goes flat or even worse,
disgusts and offends people,
then you're going to be taken aback.
And that's partly because you get what
you want and that's not so good.
But it's,
but it's more because there's something
wrong with the way you conceptualize the
situation and then you're faced with a
problem.
And the problem is the emergence of a
domain of the unknown.
It's like,
well what kind of mistake did you make?
Maybe you're not as funny as you think
you are.
Not.
That could be a big problem.
Maybe you're not around people that who
are the way you think they are.
Maybe they don't like you as much as you
thought they liked you.
I mean the,
the potential for various paranoid
thoughts of increasing severity to come
welling up at you in a situation where
you make a,
even a trivial social mistake is quite
broad.
And when you make an error of that sort,
you have to face it and sort through all
the possibilities so that you can find
out what it was that you did wrong and
how to retool it.
So that in the future you don't make the
same mistake.
And that requires,
well,
that requires in some sense what you
might describe as a journey into the
belly of the beast.
The beast being that place where things
have fallen apart and where you're
overwhelmed with negative emotion and
chaos and confusion.
And that's a very old story.
That's the story of the journey to the
underworld.
And the hero is the person who makes the
voluntary journey to the underworld to
collect what's been languishing down
there.
And that's the basic motif of
psychoanalytic theory.
I would say it's the basic motif in some
sense of clinical practice because one
of the things that you do as a clinician
is find out what people are afraid of
and what they're avoiding.
And that can be in their past or in
their present or in their future.
Break it down into smaller pieces and
help them devise strategies of approach
and mastery.
And that improves the quality of their
personality and helps develop them into
people who won't make the same mistakes
over and over again.
All right,
so,
well,
why these,
this plethora of tools?
Well,
I said in some sense being a personality
psychologist is like being an engineer.
You're trying to build better people and
you might say that if you're a carpenter
or a mechanic,
that your ability to fix a vehicle or
build a house is dependent on your
proficiency with regards to the use of a
multitude of tools.
And so then you might say,
well,
the more tools you have at your
disposal,
the more likely it is that you're going
to manage things properly.
And so what I would like to offer you is
the possibility that what you're going
to encounter in this course
is a series of sophisticated conceptual
tools that will help you understand
yourself better and therefore better
orient yourself in the world.
I regard this course is intensely
practical and that's because I believe
that you have nothing to rely on in your
life that's more crucial to your success
as you move through life,
then your character and your
personality,
that's what you bring to every
situation.
And the more sophisticated you are in
relationship to yourself and others,
the more you understand people,
the deeper you understand the nature of
your own being,
the more likely it is that you're going
to proceed through your life in a manner
that will make you pleased to exist
rather than displeased to exist.
I've collected the writings of people
that I regard as of in comparable,
brilliant.
They're difficult to understand.
Their concepts are complex,
but it's not surprising because the
subject matter is complex and vital and
so it requires work and I would say try
to keep up on the readings if you would.
It's going to make the course much more
much richer for you.
And I would say because people often ask
me,
well,
how should I read for this course?
Cause there's a lot of reading and
answer is read as if it matters.
That's the right answer.
Don't be thinking about how it's going
to be tested.
If you do the readings and you come to
the lectures,
then the tests aren't particularly
difficult.
But you should read the readings as if
the person is writing about you and you
should try to understand what the person
says because it's another tool for you
to use.
And I would say,
well with my clients,
you know I use the approaches of one
theorist for one client and the
approaches of another theorist for
another client.
It seems to me to depend to some degree
actually on the temperament of the
client.
I found for example that people who are
very high in openness,
which is the creativity dimension,
are quite amenable to a young Ian
Approach.
Whereas people who are more practical,
conscientious,
low and openness are much more amenable
to a behaviorist approach.
We don't really know enough about
psychology yet to match treatment to
temperament,
but those are the some of the things
that I've experienced.
Okay.
Practicalities.
Well there's a website I gave you the
url,
I'll put it up again at the end of
class.
The Url lists all the readings that
aren't in the textbook and so the
textbook contains the classic readings,
readings from people like young and
Freud,
piaget and so forth.
Rogers.
And as I said,
I picked that particular textbook
because I believe that the author did a
very credible job of summarizing what's
very difficult to summarize.
So and then also on the website there
are links to papers because much of the
more modern material that pertains say
to neuroscience and also to trait
personality,
I think it's better just to read the
original papers and all detail them out
with you as we go through.
And that'll also give you some
familiarity with original psychological
papers,
which are again,
there's a,
there's an idiom that you have to master
in order to understand them,
but you might as well practice it,
especially if you're interested in
continuing with psychology in your
educational practice or as a career.
It's good to get accustomed to it.
So
there again is the url for the class.
If you go to Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom,
which isn't too hard to remember,
assuming you can remember my name,
then classes are listed on the left hand
side.
You can just find the syllabus there.
MMM.
All right,
so here's what we're going to cover.
Well today,
obviously this is the introduction and
overview class is a little strange this
year because one day it's an hour and
the next day it's two hours,
so not exactly sure how we're going to
negotiate our way through that but we'll
figure it out.
Historical perspectives,
mythological representations.
Well I told you that I would try to
provide you with a Meta narrative that
might enable you to link the theories
that we're going to talk about together.
So I'm going to describe to you what you
might regard as a conceptual language
and as far as I can tell,
it's the imagine,
imagine that there are two kinds of
things that you need to know and I
believe this to be the case.
I believe that you need to know what the
world is made of and I suppose that's
the proper domain of science,
but then you need to know how to act and
that's a whole different thing and you
need to know how to act.
That's the thing.
You need to know most of anything of
anything.
Because of course you're a living
creature.
And action in relationship to desired
goals is,
is everything to you.
And you can think about that from a
Darwinian perspective.
You have to act at least so that you can
survive,
at least so that you can find a partner
that's,
that's life.
And so part of the question is,
well,
how does the world look?
If you think about it as a place to act?
And the answer isn't a place of value.
Free objects.
That's not what the world looks like.
And you can't act in a world of value
free objects because there's no way of
choosing between them.
If everything has zero value,
why would you choose one thing over
another?
You live in a world where things present
themselves to you as of different value.
And that's partly a consequence of your
temperament,
although it's consequence of other
things.
And so what I'm going to try to do is to
provide you with a Schema that describes
the world of morality,
roughly speaking,
which is how to act and tell you a
little bit about what I think the
languages,
which I think was derived from Darwinian
processes.
And I believe that it's within that
structure that the clinical theories
logically nest.
And so that'll give you a way of linking
one theory to another from a conceptual
perspective without having to rely so
much on sheer memorization.
Then we'll talk about heroic and
shamanic initiations.
And the reason we're going to do that is
because,
well,
people,
people use [inaudible] initiations for
tens of thousands of years all over the
world and they have a particular kind of
structure.
The paper by Murcia Ellie Outta which is
linked on the site is a very interesting
one in details out some of these
processes.
Um,
there have been intelligent commentators
like on [inaudible] or j who wrote the
discovery of the unconscious,
which I think is an outstanding book,
who linked the processes that the
psychoanalysts,
psychoanalysts uncovered in the late
part of the 19th century and early part
of the 20th century,
back to these more primordial rituals of
personality transformation.
And so we're going to situate ourselves
in some sense in deep history,
talking first about the underlying
mythological landscape,
then talking about archaic modes of
personality,
conceptualization and transformation.
And then moving from there into
constructivism and,
and we're going to concentrate mostly on
John Piaget who has a developmental
psychologist.
Constructivists believe that you make
yourself out of the information that you
gather in the world.
So you're an exploring creature.
You explore specifically when the maps
that you're using in the world are no
longer orienting yourself properly when
they're producing errors.
You'd go out and gather information and
assemble yourself from the information
that you discovered.
Then the depths,
psychologists,
young and Freud,
I think I'm going to with young,
I'm going to walk you through some
films.
I'm not going to use the films per se.
I'm going to use clips stills from the
film,
but in,
you know,
the film.
So in,
in chronological order,
and I'm going to try to explain to you
how you might use union presuppositions
to understand what the films are about.
You know,
if you think about a film,
say like the Lion King,
which was an extraordinarily popular
film,
it's a very strange phenomena that you
go and watch it,
right?
I mean,
think about it,
it's drawings of animated animals that
in some sense represent you.
They're very low resolution,
but you perceive them immediately as
living things and you attribute to the
motivation and,
and,
and motive power and understanding.
You do it automatically without even
thinking about it.
And there's a classic plot that lies
underneath those stories.
And the plots are very,
very,
very old.
And that's why you can understand them.
And the reason you can understand them
is because life has a plot,
or maybe it has a couple of plots,
a multitude of plots,
but life has applaud.
And if it didn't,
we wouldn't be able to understand each
other.
And so I'd like to illustrate that for
you by an analysis of some of these
films.
I think it's the best way to understand
someone as sophisticated as young who is
very difficult to get a handle on.
Freud.
I'm going to do the same thing,
although I am going to show you a film
with Freud.
I'm going to show you a film called
Crumb,
which is a documentary and it's about a
very badly in meshed family and the
attempts of the family members too,
I suppose escape it.
I'll talk to you about Freud.
I'll show you the film.
That should give you a sense of Friday
and psychopathology,
which is a very difficult thing
otherwise to understand.
Then there's a midterm.
Midterm is multiple choice.
You'll do it in class.
You'll,
you'll have lots of time to finish it.
It'll cover the material that we took.
We studied up to that point.
Then we're going to talk about Rogers.
Carl Rogers who was a humanist.
Rogers has a body centered philosophy I
suppose and he's interested as well in
optimal personal development and the
role that interpersonal communication
plays in that Rogers hypothesis.
Fundamentally,
and it's a very interesting one,
is that honest communication between two
people can produce personality
transformation.
And you know,
you might think,
well you kind of know that already
because there's something very engaging
about a deep,
honest conversation where you're able to
say things that you wouldn't normally
say,
where you're being listened to by
someone who's actually listening to you
and you're listening to them and in the
conversation you're moving both of you
further to a different point.
That's different than a conversation
where you're right and you're trying to
convince me or I'm right and I'm trying
to convince you,
which I would say is the typical
conversation.
The,
the healing conversation is more,
well,
what's up with you?
You know,
how are you doing?
What,
how's your life going?
Where,
what sort of problems are you facing?
What do you think about those problems?
Can you conceptualize what a solution
might be?
Is there a way we could figure out how
to get there?
You know,
it's,
so,
it's a problem solving conversation and
it's predicated on the presupposition
that the person that you're conversing
with has the capacity to grow.
In a positive direction if they so
choose.
That's the fundamental,
that's the fundamental presupposition of
Rogerian psychology.
May and Frankl are also humanists
all finished.
Tell you what the rest of the rest of
the material is.
The next time that we meet,
I should show you,
let you know a little bit more about the
structure of the course.
The second midterm is March 14th,
the and there's a final at the end as
well.
So
the,
the multiple choice tests are graded in
that manner.
25% 25% in 27.5%.
They're not cumulative.
Each test only covers what you covered
before,
since the last test,
including the final,
you'll be required to write an essay of
15%.
It's a thousand words,
sorry,
not 750 words.
And you'll also do an online exercise,
a personality analysis,
um,
which is pass fail.
All you have to do is complete it and
show proof of completion.
It helps you do a modified big five
analysis of your own personality,
concentrating on your virtues and your
faults.
So that so,
so it's uh,
it's an active exercise in the
application of personality theory to
personal development.
And so that's the,
that's the structure of the course.
Um,
I can tell you
there's a signup sheet on the,
on the syllabus.
We,
I've broken the essays down into
multiple types across the entire
semester.
I would highly recommend that you go
there and sign up.
There are limited slots for each topic.
And the reason for that is,
well,
I don't want my ta to have to grade 200
essays the last week of classes.
We have to spread them out across the
year.
So figure out a topic and sign up
please.
And please do that sooner rather than
later.
It's,
it's an industrious thing to do.
It'll help you organize yourself.
I'll post something that's quite useful
about how to write,
especially a thousand word essay and
I'll close the essays are due one day
before class.
Oh,
close.
By the way,
by telling you who shouldn't take this
course.
Okay.
First of all,
if you didn't like this lecture,
then don't take this course because this
is what the lectures are going to be
like.
So,
and they're not for everybody.
Um,
I use a lot of loose associations and
try to gather them back in and I kind of
wander around that way.
I can talk directly to you,
which I liked doing,
but I sacrifice a certain amount of
organization for that.
But my stance is that it's worth the
sacrifice.
The second thing is there's a lot of
reading a lot and a lot of it is,
I would say a lot of it's hard science,
the last half in particular,
but the first half of a lot of its
philosophical in nature,
philosophical,
slash,
psychological.
And so if you're not interested in that,
like if you're a pure science type and
you're not interested in the clinical
elements,
say have personality and in the end in
investigating the philosophical
underpinnings of those clinical
theories,
then I would say this isn't the course
for you.
And so you should take that seriously
because the readings are hard.
There's a lot of work involved in this
course.
And it would be better if you took a
course that you actually wanted to take.
So,
well,
welcome to psychology to 30 and we'll
see you in a bit.